flu season begins in April in Australia
and gives Canadians a glimpse into the
future so doctors watch that data
closely the numbers seem to be a bit
below or at the same level as prior
years pre-pandemic there was a kind of
early sharp rise and then a decline that
that happened a bit earlier than
expected but is our flu season
approaches doctors say getting that flu
shot is a tough sell I'm worried because
people are tired of vaccination they're
tired of cold shots and by extension
they're tired of all shots Dr to Brian
Conway says vaccines are key to keeping
people out of the hospital if we let our
guard down and we have too low an uptake
of vaccination for covet and flu that
that'll lead to increased to
transmission and will potentially stress
the Health Care System more
significantly than it can bear 43
percent of Canadians got a flu shot last
year 74 percent of seniors were
vaccinated but that falls short of the
80 percent coverage goal twenty one
percent of those who didn't get a shot
said they just didn't get around to it
making time is critical especially for
children under two and those who are
immunocompromised says pediatric
specialist Dr Jesse papenberg roughly 15
to 20 percent of children who get
admitted actually require ICU care so
they are critically ill and require some
sort of ventilatory support or other
assistance in terms of maintaining their
finals and doctors say while you're
rolling up one sleeve you might roll up
the other and get an updated covid-19
shot at the same time it's important
that we take the opportunities when one
vaccine is being administered to make
sure people are up to date let's just uh
one and done go get your vaccine and uh
maybe be part of the solution Catherine
Ward Global News Toronto